hey comedy huh alright good to be here
sorry little hungover went out last
night with a friend
he's like a beer expert you know one of
these guys like we got to go to a
brewery I'm like why can't we go to a
bar he's it gets fun you can see how
it's made I don't care how it's made
look I like porn I don't need to go to a
broken home I'm saying all points aren't
broken home just the ones I like yeah my
friends a gay guy he's obsessed with
straight dudes that's like his thing
he's like I love flipping a hetero he's
like you know how hard that is
you know Hardee's go out there every
night see a bunch of people you want to
have sex with who don't have sex with
you I was like that's exactly it's like
being a straight guy what the hell you
talk about I would argue it's just hard
for me to sleep with a woman is for you
to flip a hetero he was like no no no
you gotta take him out for hours
convince him yeah yeah same here he's
like no no even if you do pull off which
is like a miracle they feel horrible
after yeah yeah same thing we went back
and forth for hours talking about this
all night back and forth eventually I
woke up at his place
oh yeah I'm not gay I got a girlfriend
she's cool I'm surprised she's still
with me because I always say the wrong
thing like on our first date she was
like you know I feel very brave tonight
I was like why is that cuz I'm not
wearing makeup I was like how's that
brave cuz I'm being my true self being
the real me I was like oh okay she's
like you should be brave oh yeah maybe I
will
she's like what he gonna do I was like
I'm gonna stop pretending this is
interesting
she was like wow I can't believe he just
said that I was like yeah it took guts
but it's good to be with somebody cuz
those dating apps those aren't fun you
know every girl would always ask me how
tall I was
you ladies are all a bunch of filthy
height supremacist you over six feet you
over six feet over six feet I feel bad I
feel like I could come up with something
I was like well no but if it helps I'm
still growing as a person
I don't know we can ask physical stuff
out of the gate I was like how much do
you weigh she was like whoa that's body
shaming it's hard for me to lose weight
well it's harder for me to gain height
you know we've been talk about women's
issues a lot now which is good one issue
I'm surprised doesn't come up is I feel
like women are getting screwed in the
orgasm Department feel like men are
having way more orgasms and women and
that sucks people talk about the wage
gap the orgasm gap is out of control
right you gals are getting 77 cents to
the boner like if a woman had to have an
orgasm to get pregnant they'd be like
two people here
and you get nothing for orgasm like I'm
a guy as an orgasm go get pregnant carry
babe for nine months deliver the baby
then breastfeed the baby and all the guy
to do is this and he tried really hard
not do that so horrible setup for the
woman the guy is all the fun the girl is
all the work that'd be like if I ate a
whole chocolate cake and the girl gained
weight then she went to the gym and I
got buff but you guys are nice a lot of
crowds very sensitive now you know
everybody went and got upset about words
I got yelled at the other night this guy
goes hey buddy that's a trigger word I
was like whoa I think it's pronounced
trigger
easy there big fella yeah you can't talk
about much racial jokes that's hard to
pull off
let's try one white privilege you hear
about that a lot now white privilege but
I thought it was all about diversity so
shouldn't we talk about everybody's
privileges why were just limiting it to
whitey let's spread the love let's make
every group feel good everybody's got
something to all people privilege see
the concert Jews no hell pretty good
pretty good women ladies night that's
cool black people I can't wear a purple
suit looks like fun
everybody's got a perk Indian people
even if you're undateable your parents
will arrange something huh let's spread
the love but I'm a white guy you know so
if I talk about race and everybody
another white person will call me racist
that's like what we do now you know I
can't even know me that's quite an
accusation you know that's an important
word you're gonna take the teeth out of
it you know like I was on the subway
where you say I was watching an
interracial couple make out I was just
staring at them and the guy next to them
caught me he goes what the hell I see
you staring at them what are you racist
I was like what racist no I'm a creep
what are you talking about I'm hard not
a racist I'm aroused he was like wow who
talks like that I'm like well I'm pretty
brave
[Applause]